okay so let's pick up where we left off
let's first have a look at this worked
example and the relative frequencies so
like I mentioned before all you're
really going to do is take the frequency
which is already provided 9 7 20 and so
on and then you are going to divide by
the total number which I think you've
all calculated is 72
okay so the relative frequency of the
first class will be 9 out of 72 then 7
out of 72 20 out of 72 you get the idea
okay now to sketch that frequency
histogram I know it takes a while to
draw a chart I didn't give you heaps of
time but this is basically what it's
going to look like you can see you've
got each of the classes there you could
either have drawn in the class center as
you can see on this graph or you could
have marked in the beginning and ends of
each class so 45 and then 50 and you
would have the bar going between those
either then would have been fine and
then you can see the heights there
represent the relative frequency so
that's why the vertical axis you can see
they don't go up to like 20 and 30
it goes up to 0.4 whatever it happens to
be I'm not sure what I'm 30 out of 72 is
actually equal to as a decimal but you
get the idea okay so how we use this to
be able to estimate the probabilities
well we do this just like we did with
the dice even though this is a
continuous random variable you can see
I've broken it up into a situation that
looks exactly like this chart looks
exactly like I mean not exactly like the
shapes not the same but the structure of
it is it the same as when we were
looking at the dice so this might as
well be a discrete situation for when I
answer these questions the probability
of the time of the runner being less
than 55 less than or equal to that is
just the first two classes or I
shouldn't say the lowest two classes the
45 to 50 and then the 50 to 55 maybe
Louis is not the best way it's that it's
the fastest right they have the shortest
time okay so all you would do is you
would add up 9 over 72 plus 7 over 72
and that'll give you the probability so
what's that 16 on 72 and you would
simplify that if you wanted okay
conversely the probability of the time
the running time being greater than or
equal to 60 instead of taking the two
fastest classes here I'm taking the two
slowest classes so there's 60 to 65
and the 65 to 70 class and then finally
you've got the one in the middle there a
probability of being between 50 and 65
so that's the middle three classes okay
now like I mentioned before this is
taking a continuous random variable and
basically sort of in imposing a discrete
structure on it like there's a discrete
number a distinct number of classes and
then you can treat each one independent
independently individually and add up
the probabilities as you need but the
whole point of this topic and it's going
to take us to the end of the term to
really explore this is to say well can't
we work out a way to treat continuous
random variables in a continuous way is
there a way that I can solve these
problems work our probabilities make
predictions without resorting to my
discrete tools and my discrete
structures can I treat them continuously
okay so let's return back to this graph
that we had for the heights of people in
the class okay this probability density
function if what I want is the
probability between two particular
boundaries a lower boundary enough
boundary as most of you connected before
I'm trying to work out an area under a
curve and we have all of the knowledge
developed over the last couple of months
to be able to do this this is an
integral isn't it this is the whole
point of actually putting integral
calculus between all that statistics we
learn and now write we needed integral
calculus to be able to handle these
areas yeah so what I can say is the
probability if it's equal to the area
under the curve then the probability is
equal to the integral between those two
relevant boundaries underneath this
function so the probability is given by
the integral from A to B of this
function f of X where f of X is whatever
probability density function that you'd
like okay now I'd like you to make that
heading probability density functions
because that's what we're now going to
focus on okay
now probably the density functions the f
of X that we that we choose they really
can be all different kinds of things so
for example we had you know this is the
kind of shape that I gave you of the
heights but that that sort of died
situation before it looked more like
this right it was lower it was more
symmetrical you might have weird other
kinds of continuous rain
variables that do this right there's no
reason why you can't have data that
behaves like this and so all you need to
do is pick a function that is
appropriate to that right except that
you can't just pick any function because
this is a probability function there are
a couple of conditions that need to be
satisfied right so let's first jot down
right we want to have this result that
we are working out probabilities between
certain boundaries we're working these
out by way of an integral so A to B f of
X okay if this is the case that we use
this integral to work out the
probability then there are two
conditions that you must satisfy if you
want to be a probability density
function okay two conditions so what are
those conditions well firstly when we
think about situations right if
something is likely to happen then it
has a probability that's close to one
right if something is certain it has a
probability of one if something is
unlikely to happen it has a probability
close to zero and if it cannot possibly
happen then its probability is equal to
zero right um what you can't ever have
is a probability that's negative yeah
I'm probably straight from 0 to 1
inclusive okay so what we're saying
therefore is your function your
probability density function it must be
greater than or equal to zero because
you can't have a negative probability
does that make sense okay so that's the
first condition which as you can see
you're like wait a second a lot of
functions I know they they go negative
well we'll come to solving that problem
in a second that's the first thing and
then the second is remember we said when
we look at the dice without any
calculation when I asked you what's the
probability between 2 and 12 you all
could say without adding up all of the
bars and all the values you could say
it's equal to 1 because that's what the
total probability of any situation is
equal to how would we express that how
we articulate that fact that all your
total probabilities are equal 1 using
the language of integral calculus
well this integral number one has to
include everything right has to include
everything which means you go from as
far left as you possibly can negative
- as far right as you possibly can -
positive infinity when you integrate
that function if that function really
does give you probabilities then they
should total all of the probabilities
possible they should total to be equal
to one okay so what we're saying here is
your total your total situation must add
up to one because otherwise you've
missed something right if you're like oh
I added up all my probabilities in there
up to the 0.99 they that means you're
missing something right so this actually
has sort of a sub implication okay the
fact that I'm your pro bilities have to
add up to one
this causes us a bit of an issue if for
example we go back to this weird-looking
graph over here right you don't need to
draw this but you can if you want right
you can see here that suppose right I
have this section that I've drawn and
I'm just gonna put some boundaries in
here let's say from here to here suppose
this area under this curve equals to one
okay but if you've got like this maybe
was like a weird polynomial which had
it's got six six it's got five
stationary points so maybe this is like
an extra power of six type function okay
and we know that there's like other
parts of this function just just like
stop existing
I'm in my go down here in my wake wave
around and do other things over here or
or this might skyrocket off to infinity
so you're gonna have other parts of the
function which like you kind of don't
want to really deal with because if you
included them your total integral
wouldn't add up to one okay so how do we
get around this right what we do is we
define f of X in a particular way what
we do is we say look this particular
function that's sort of helpful to us
its shape is useful to us we will let
the probability density function equal
this particular function but only
between the values that were interested
in so if I want to go from A to B right
then I say you're equal to this function
between a and B and supposing they're
between a and B Y or you add up all of
that area and you equal to one then I
don't want any more area to be added
right or subtracted for that matter so
everywhere
I say that that function our probability
density function is just zero okay if
you are less than your lower boundary or
if you are greater shouldn't include the
boundary there if you're greater than
your upper boundary everywhere else
except inside here you just let your
probability density function equal to
zero okay so what that means is it's it
has a practical effect of ignoring these
parts of the function that if you
include them in your integral it
wouldn't add up to one okay so I know
that's a bit tricky like it's very
symbol and and notation heavy so if you
look at this and thinking my brain hurts
okay that's that's understandable I know
that this is very new to you and I
promise with time you become more
comfortable with it okay but basically
we're we're gonna head from here is the
first things we're gonna think about are
what functions can be probability
density functions and what ones can't
right what characteristics do they have
so we're going to explore that next
lesson well done on wrapping your head
around this I know it's complicated and
new but it's because this is such a
powerful lens for looking at the world
and that's why when you take statistics
and you take calculus and you combine
them it ends up being immensely useful
for a variety of practical situations
which we'll get to later okay well done
everyone see you next lesson